hey guys my name is China welcome back
to my C plus plus Series right
so you're sick of being alone
you just you need to connect with the
world this whole solo thing you said it
was good you said you loved it but it's
over and now now you want to connect to
other computers what use is the world if
we're not connected so many quotes so
many great quotes So how do you write
programs in C plus that are capable of
communicating communicating with the
outside world communicating with other
computers on your local network how does
one learn the art of that well you've
certainly picked like the best language
for the job I mean c plus Plus's library
has everything including
oh there's no there's no there's no
built-in networking I don't know why I
decided to treat this video like a TV
show I'm sorry but yeah it's true like C
plus plus has no built-in networking at
all you have to use the operating system
apis like the win32 API for example if
you want to use sockets and any other
things that let you communicate with
devices every other language you know I
don't know like c-sharp Java python they
all kind of have you know that built in
but sure you know C plus plus ubu never
change C plus plus do people say that
anyway I'll stop just in a joking mood
today
um so first of all let's kind of talk
about what I mean by like networking in
C plus like what does that mean
basically what I'm talking about is
using sockets now these sockets can be
used to transport data from one place to
another and it could be as simple as
like even on the same computer you know
you could open up a socket that can
receive data and you can send it like
from that same kind of computer that's
called like a loopback you could also
communicate to another computer on your
local network so that doesn't involve
the use of something called a wide area
network or a Wan it's just kind of on
the land the local area network and in
terms of like networking Hardware you
could just have like a switch or I mean
you could even use one of those ethernet
cables I remember we had back in the day
it's like instead of being like uh
what's it called you know they were like
red or something
ah here we go a crossover cable that's
what it's called an Ethernet crossover
cable oh man that just brings me back to
like high school when we want to play
like you know a lan game but they'd
block it or something in the firewall on
the local network I guess at school and
so we had to like people tried to like
connect ethernet cables one computer to
another and it wouldn't really work
because I think that I mean the wiring
has to be different so you need like a
special cable anyway a little bit
sidetracked here but then it could also
be like across the internet and of
course that involves like using a router
and like the things that could go wrong
there like you might need to afford your
ports might need to tame your firewall a
little bit you could obviously just use
like a server you know like from hosting
out the sponsor of this video which
we'll get to later but that's basically
what I'm talking about and I'm not gonna
go into like the deep deep fundamentals
of networking a because I'm not an
expert on that stuff and B because I
just kind of want to practically show
you how you can just get this working
even though I love having a deep
understanding of things and teaching
that wherever possible I feel like
that's not always necessary and at the
end of the day you just kind of want to
write code that's just like send data to
this address please and receive data as
well and as long as you can write that
code and it works like you can get on
with your day and and make the thing
you're actually trying to make so yeah
so that's basically what we're going to
be talking about today what we aren't
going to be talking about today but I do
want to cover this in a later video is
stuff like HTTP so if you want to just
download information from a web server
via HTTP so you can kind of you know
make get or post requests or stuff like
that or everything to do with the kind
of HTTP protocol and yes I know the p
and HTTP stands for protocol but it
makes more sense if you say in the HTTP
protocol instead of in the http
I mean I don't know maybe maybe I should
say in the HTTP yeah so that will cover
in a different video so today is
basically all about how do I send data
from one thing to another and also be
able to receive data from that thing
we're connecting two things together I
mean honestly it's gonna be more than
two things it's gonna be like one thing
acting as their server and then all
these clients as many as you want really
limited by I guess Hardware connecting
to that one thing so a server client
kind of architecture and you can just
send whatever you want really between
the two in either a reliable way or an
unreliable way so how can we do that in
C plus now there are a number of
networking libraries in C plus plus and
I guess drawing from kind of like the
time that I made the like the best way
to make desktop applications in C plus
plus video which I'll link up there by
the way I don't want to use libraries
like qt or cute I don't like there's
this other thing called asio which to me
just like reminds me of the audio driver
to be completely on but there's burst
ass here like anything with Boost in it
like I don't want to do that you know
you feel me that's just my vibe I guess
that's just what I'm it's just who I am
and speaking of who I am I mean I'm a
I'm a game engine programmer like I make
game engines and I like making games so
that's kind of the world I live in so
that's that's what I'm gonna base my
recommendations on that's what we're
gonna kind of do today we're going to
use something that's going to be
compatible with you know a game engine
and how you do things in a game engine
much like that desktop applications and
C plus video because you've come to my
channel you've come to my world so the
library that we're going to use is
actually by Valve by Valve software you
know like Steam
Half-Life Counter-Strike Team Fortress I
don't know what are they doing these
days just making money from the steam
commissions I guess the steam cut they
have a library called game networking
sockets here it is on GitHub it says
failing but it's it's actually a good
library and it's succeeding in my heart
so this thing is just on GitHub like for
you to use you can see that you can send
reliable and unreliable messages over
UDP so it doesn't use TCP but it works
like TCP so it's not only Bound by the
potential limitations of TCP it just
kind of uses the UDP protocol the UDP
which is important for kind of games and
performance that kind of stuff it's got
some really great features you know I'll
leave a link to this obviously in the
description below check it out for
yourselves and even though like in the
API the word steam is used like a lot it
does not require Steam and the license
is also extremely permissive so you can
you can of course use this outside of
steam for whatever you like and that's
what I did I thought the best way to
kind of put this into action and like
create a practical example this would be
to just make like an application so I
made my own like instant messaging chat
application yeah like Cherno chat back
in the day the network chat programming
series for those of you who are ogs on
my channel oh it's just coming full
circle isn't it except this one's called
Walnut chat instead of China chat Cherno
chat is that's vintage you know that's
like weird that's Legacy stuff we don't
touch that so that's what the rest of
this video is going to be about it's
going to be about how I made that
application I'll walk you guys through
my kind of development journey of that
uh but like yeah it totally works I'll
leave the link obviously to all of the
source code that's on GitHub you can
also download the release and like I'll
leave the server up for the time being
so you can actually connect to like this
URL using the client which you can
download and like you can you can yeah I
mean it works I mean is it like a
hundred percent secure and are people
going to hack it probably but hopefully
the code is going to be like a good
example and a good starting point for
those of you who want to develop
something like this where you can just
arbitrarily send data to and from a
client server and uh yeah like in a pro
about like you know GUI application so
coming back to the beginning of all of
this I knew I wanted to make a chat
application just because I feel like a
chat application like is it's almost
like a hello world of like networking
like if you want to send data to and
from something like sure you could
integrate into a game maybe but like I
mean even games have chat usually like
text chat so it kind of makes sense that
you would create some kind of chat
client at least that's what it feels
like to me and so luckily for me and
actually to further my point there's an
example that is included with this game
networking sulcus repository that is
this example Chat thing and it's a
command line program you can download
it's all entirely within one file and
you just start it with like a command
line argument of either like client or
server depending on what mode you want
to run it in and that's it that's your
chat application so that's kind of what
I based this on however like it ended up
being something completely different I
ended up kind of learning a lot from
that and abstracting that into actually
a separate module for Walnut called
Walnut networking because I knew that I
wanted to use Walnut as like the core
Library since I I wanted to have like a
GUI here and by the way if those who
don't know what Walnut is Walnut is kind
of like my application framework that I
created which I ended up updating quite
a bit actually for this video and for
this project so this video is going to
end up being like a high level overview
of all the different moving parts and
how they come together to make this
Walnut Chat thing happen we'll start by
taking a look at the actual game
networking soccer's library and how to
get started with that as well as how I
took that and integrated it into walnut
walnut networking and then the separate
kind of client application and server
application we'll have a look at the
actual game networking sockets API and
I'll talk about how that went into
Walnut networking and how I used it you
know to actually establish connections
and data to and from Severin client that
kind of stuff the server application
obviously needs to be able to run you
know like on a server so we'll talk
about a headless configuration for
Walnut which enables it to be run inside
a terminal how I got the server
compiling on Linux and this kind of
Linux yeah if you can see it this is a
this is this computer over here is a a a
Linux computer that we have in the
office how I got headless wall not
running there like inside a terminal
with that game networking sockets
Library so that we could have the server
there and then finally we'll deploy it
onto an actual real hostinger server and
that's how the whole chat dot the
general.com thing that you guys can
connect to that's what's currently
running now hosting were nice enough to
sponsor this video and provide us with a
server to use which is great because
they provide full route access giving us
complete control over our server I mean
we could even use it as a Dev machine
like if you don't have a Linux machine
you can just use one of their servers
and build your code there that plus the
fact that they use nvme drives and AMD
epic processors mean they're always a
pleasure to use they're just fast and
responsive we'll cover setting one up
later in this video as part of the
deployment so we'll kind of have like a
nice big overview of the whole process
now for those of you who would like more
detail like I am planning to make some
deeper videos but just leave some
comments Below on what you'd like to see
and I'll try to make that happen step
one the library so game networking
sockets on GitHub all of the source code
here important as all always to read the
license make sure that you can actually
use this you can see it's the bsd3
license so pretty good now usually what
I'll do while this is cloning is take a
look at the building section in the
readme it's amazing how often people
don't do this instead of just like
seeing a cmake file for example and
being like I'm just going to see make
this it's really important that you just
take a look at the building under the
readme especially when it like you know
has its own page like this uh because it
covers like all the dependencies and
stuff it tells you how to build it on
Linux which we know we're going to have
to do later but since we are on Windows
that just happens to be my kind of
default development environment and also
I obviously want to run the client on
Windows as well you can see that their
recommendation here is just to use VC
package for that I'm not a huge fan of
VC package but when I'm building other
people's libraries especially ones that
are fairly complex like this one like
it's got plenty of dependencies such as
openssl and B Crypt and like protobuf
and a bunch of other stuff that I don't
want to deal with I'm just going to
follow their recommended build path and
there are manuals instructions like if
you don't want to do that but like
that's a lot of extra work it's really
nice when developers actually spend some
time to guide you through every step of
building something like this once we've
cloned the actual game networking circus
repository you can see that it guides us
through every single command line like
step that we need to run through so we
just kind of Clone VC package right
there into that game networking sockets
repository and then we launch a video
Studio like developer command prompt
which is this special thing that you can
do if you just like hit start and search
for developer command prompts you'll
probably find it and then we just like
run these commands now one thing that I
did do differently was they in this
example just show using ninja as the
kind of build system I guess for this so
they'll use cmake but they'll generate
like ninja build files and then actually
build using ninja that's cool but I
wanted to use Visual Studio might as
well so I just changed this to be like
you know Visual Studio basically I think
it's like Visual Studio 22 or something
I don't know just the normal kind of
where you would get cmake to generate
you know instead of a ninja build files
it would generate a visual studio
solution and Proto files and so once
that was done I could just open Visual
Studio I could build like a debug
configuration a release configuration
whatever really I wanted those kind of
built binaries that's what I use to link
into Walnut so I didn't bother actually
trying to get this to work within Walnut
itself for larger kind of third-party
libraries I just like to build them like
Standalone and obviously like I'll I'll
retain and make sure I have access to
all of the source code in that separate
project just in case I need to build it
with a different compiler or for a
different platform but I still like to
keep that Standalone because integrating
this into like walnut would be much much
much harder and also quite frankly just
unnecessary so once that was done I took
a look at the examples so as I mentioned
there is this chat example I just had a
look at this like in Visual Studio made
sure I understood it ran through like
most of this code this one file as I
mentioned earlier actually has both the
client and the server in it so the idea
areas like the usage let's see if we can
find the usage here here it is print
usage and exit so basically you called
you you call this through the command
line and then you just say client or
server and it runs whatever
configuration you want and you can see
that obviously it like starts either
this chat client or chat server class so
if we go up and take a look at this you
know this is obviously what starting the
server does and that's the steam
networking kind of API in use and this
is kind of what I used as a reference to
determine what I needed to actually set
up inside Walnut networking for the
client and the server API okay so for
step two I had to set up a new Walnut
project uh I have this Walnut app
template over here on my GitHub this is
an actual template that you can use you
can just hit use this template create a
new repository I went through this to
create this kind of Walnut chat
repository and that way I got everything
kind of set up for me which is great
here it is networking and CPP that was
the original name before I came up with
this whole Walnut Chat thing and then I
just kind of tweaked the build scripts I
actually ended up doing quite a lot of
work here because I also needed that
headless configuration which we'll
discuss in the future but I basically
ended up creating a few different
projects Here app Client app server app
common which sits between these two and
then inside Walnut this kind of Walnut
networking module and you can see that
this actual Walnut networking module
this is kind of what ends up linking
this game networking sockets Library
I'll put up a little diagram so that you
can see how all of these kind of
projects are linked together now I
thought it would be useful to also
quickly cover what the actual steam API
even looks like again I would recommend
you just look at that chat example that
is inside the game networking sockets
repository but basically if we look at
the server class inside Walnut
networking module you can see that the
first thing we do is try and initialize
game networking sockets we then create
this kind of interface from it this will
actually create a different interface
depending on I guess the version of the
library but also whether or not you're
using it in conjunction with steam
because you can use this with steam but
you can also use it completely not
having anything to do with steam like we
are here we're then going to just set up
this kind of local address with a port
any kind of configuration options we
want and then we create this listen
socket IP which is going to be using
that port and options and stuff that we
specified now this interface this steam
networking sockets that's like your API
that's what you use to call any of these
game networking sockets API commands so
here we're using it to create a list and
socket IP we create something called a
poll Group which at the moment again
will not we'll just create it for you
but that's basically like a group of
clients that you can use to I guess more
efficiently process messages from and
send messages to I mean like one thing I
didn't mention is that you can see I'm
in the header file now this is the I
steam networking sockets.h this is like
the whole API basically and you can see
just how good this header file is like a
look at this documentation it's all here
it's wonderful I love this so you can
see what poll groups are poll groups a
poll group is a set of connections that
can be pulled efficiently and you'll see
us kind of using that a bit later so we
try and create that and then we just set
up a while running Loop which every
iteration will sleep for 10 milliseconds
just to kind of reduce server load that
should probably also be configurable
follow incoming messages well you
probably guessed it it'll try and
receive messages from our poll group
that we created and then if there's no
messages we just break out of this kind
of while running Loop because if we have
more than one we'll kind of iterate
multiple times less than zero I think is
a critical error because that's what the
example seems to suggest and then this
kind of message that we receive is
stored inside this and that's got a size
so this is the size of the message and
then it's got a data pointer which is
the data for the message so you can see
we can immediately just create like a
walnut buffer out of it and then just
call the data received callback so
that's kind of incoming messages the
other really important part though is
this kind of run callbacks thing which
that will invoke all the Callback
functions queued for this interface
which really is this which is really
really important I guess unless you're
using steam so what that will do it'll
call this kind of connection status
change callback which will redirect to
this function and that will look at the
connection state that has possibly
changed so this is important because
this lets us handle client connections
and disconnections so like if someone's
trying to connect we can choose to
accept that connection if that fails you
know we'll close it whatever and then
assign that client that poll group and
also you know call Our Kind of Walnut
callbacks and stuff like that but you
can see we also registered that
connected client and we end up storing
them inside the connected clients map so
that we can then do things like send
messages to everyone and just have a
record that that client even exists and
is currently connected that's really all
there is to this game network in
soccer's API like of course it's got
many many more features but at its core
that's how it works and the client side
of it is very similar the only real
difference is that instead of create
listen socket IP we call connect by IP
address like that's kind of it you have
the same kind of income pulling incoming
messages except there's received
messages on connection instead of on
poll group uh there's still the same
connection status changed situation so
yeah that's kind of the API so once I
heard all of this running and I was kind
of happy with the features that I had
both on the client and the server more
or less I knew that since I had to have
it run on Linux and in a terminal like
without I am gooey without Vulcan
without the UI because the end game was
of course deployed onto a hostinger
server which is just like a regular you
know Linux server that doesn't have a
GUI at all so I knew that this clearly
wouldn't work at all I needed to set up
a version of this server that ran just
as like a command line application and
so to make things easier I just did it
here on Windows I didn't bother like
moving onto like some kind of Linux
development environment or anything like
that I'll just get it to work here like
as a command line application on Windows
first then I'll make it work on Linux
then I'll deploy it onto the server and
so that's where this kind of networking
and CPP headless was born and just this
whole concept of Walnut being able to be
built in a headless configuration now a
headless configuration by the way means
basically command line program so no UI
no no window no windowing Library no
Graphics API like Vulcan or whatever
just pure terminal kind of command line
goodness and so you can see that in this
project what we have is all not headless
while not networking That Remains the
Same um and then we have the server app
and guess what this is the exact same
server app the only difference here is
that it will not set a menu bar callback
which has I'm gooey stuff because we
don't have I'm GUI uh the wall art
application is a bit different so you
can see it includes either application
headless or application GUI depending on
what configuration we're building in and
by the way application to headless and
application GUI they're under platform
either GUI or headless meaning that we
can just not build platform GUI if we've
got a headless configuration I might
make a separate video about how this
headless stuff works because I don't
want to take up too much of this video
for that but the really cool thing is
that like again it's exactly the same
code like this is not a duplicated file
that's why it has these kind of if and
Def headless and stuff because like this
code obviously won't compile what I
thought was also really cool is that
there's actually a different console so
we have that UI console and we have a
headless console as well and this
headless console matches this UI console
in API perfectly which is why inside
have this app file Whenever I Call
console dot like add message or whatever
like it doesn't matter if it's a
headless console or a walnut UI console
like the API is just identical and over
here where we also set a message send
callback that's also identical so if we
type in a message into the UI console
hit enter it calls our send chat message
and then if we do the same thing but
inside the terminal and hit enter same
situation so that's great because we
don't have to change anything like this
code doesn't even know if it's running
headless or not which is fantastic and
if I just demonstrate that for you guys
by running this uh then here we are you
can see it's exactly the same as like
what that UI version looks like
um
and I can type here and I'll receive
messages here um and everything works
the same way so once I had that running
on Windows and obviously this actual
like binary that gets built here that
doesn't link Vulcan that doesn't link
I'm GUI nothing I knew that it was
basically ready to be run on Linux I
just needed to make sure that I you know
made sure that the the build scripts
there was also like a version here that
will build it for Linux using clang
because that's what I wanted to use you
can see It'll call build headless and I
decided to use gmake2 which is a remake
build platform I guess that will
generate these kind of make files that I
could then just run to compile the
program because I didn't really want to
bother using an ID inside Linux this is
a fairly simple project okay so over
here on the Ubuntu computer to build
game networking sockets just go down to
the building inside the GitHub
repository and there's a Linux section
very very easy to build this on Linux
compared to Windows I mean I guess VC
package wasn't that difficult but this
is easier all I did was this and then
you can use ninja or just normal mag
files to build it now in order to build
our actual server our Walnut chat server
basically what I did is I just modified
the pre-mag files to where necessary
also have a Linux configuration for
linking so you can see over here that
I'm linking the game networking sockets
library from this path and of course
this is the path where I put the binary
that we built by building game
networking sockets on Linux once that
was done inside the scripts folder
there's this setup.sh file
if I just run that
and then that's going to run pre-make to
generate those gmag to kind of build
files so now what we have are these make
files everywhere so like app server you
can see also has it we basically just
use pre-make to generate those make
files so if we go back a directory now
we can just run make and you can see
it's going to start building our server
and all of the dependencies as well so
Walnut headless well not networking app
common headless app server headless all
of those are being built this is just in
a debug configuration but you can see
it's done it's linked to successfully
and now inside the bin directory debug
Linux app server headless we have our
app server headless file and this is
just me copying the dynamic Library
manually into this directory so that we
can then basically take these two files
a little bit later on and put them onto
our server obviously before we deploy
this onto our server it would be a good
idea to just try kind of running it
locally over here that's what I did I
made sure that I could communicate over
the local network between this computer
running like the server obviously on
Linux and then also my Windows computer
once that was all working I was say it's
basically ready to be deployed onto the
server now I am planning to make a bit
of a deeper Linux video where I'm going
to be adding like Linux GUI kind of
support to Walnut because Walnut at the
moment only supports Windows we have
this headless Walnut configuration now
which does support Linux that's how this
is working but I still want to be able
to run like the chat client on Linux you
know using imgui and Vulcan and
rendering just like we do on windows so
if you want to see more Linux videos and
walnut kind of related stuff let me know
it's time to deploy this onto a real
server that's where the sponsor of this
video comes in hosting us so hosting it
has a bunch of really nice server plans
that we can use here uh we're going to
need a VPS we don't have to worry too
much about choosing you know a more
expensive plan you can just go with like
the cheapest plan and then just upgrade
uh their prices as you can see are
pretty good uh but if you have a coupon
code which you guys do
you type in a Cherno here and hit apply
and then once that's ready to go we can
just hit setup follow the prompts I
guess I'll set one up in the US I
usually try and pick whatever's closest
to like where most of you guys are I'm
just gonna go for a plain OS to be
honest we're gonna go with Ubuntu uh we
can give it a name uh root password so
definitely not share this with you guys
save and continue finish setup now we'll
wait and actually in the meantime just
open up a command prompt and we'll get
ready to ssh in so SSH and then whatever
the IP address we get assigned to the
server will be That's How we'll get in
all right so once that's done let's hit
manage server there's the IP address
let's copy that back in here SSH right
into that uh hit Yes actually forgot to
say do root out let's cancel that so SSH
make sure you do root at and then that
so that we log in as this user we put in
our password our root password which uh
seems to have failed but I forget my
root password already I just made it now
you can actually update your root
password which is a useful feature ah 10
minutes that's really okay it's done all
right that was good that took like 10
seconds let's try and log in again uh
okay we're in I don't know what happened
there I don't know I don't know what I
must have entered maybe I made a mistake
during entering my reports but anyway so
there we go we're on the server now yeah
uh from here there's several different
ways we could get access to our code
obviously if you're just using git and
something like GitHub or gitlab you can
just do like get clone and just check
out your repository that way now this is
a fresh server so I don't think we we
don't have it so you'll have to do like
uh let's do a pseudo update first let's
make this full screen um and then we'll
just do uh you know install git yes
um and then there you go gets installed
if you've got like a binary release that
you've already got compiled like we just
did you know on that computer behind me
you can just download that from a web
server so if you have it like as a
release on GitHub for example you can
get it from there just using using wget
or something like that if you've got it
locally you can just use FTP to upload
it uh I think what I want to do is I'm
just going to pull it off that computer
and upload it like to the server uh okay
so I've just uploaded it using filezilla
um I made a directory called
app and then in here you can see that we
have
um the app server headless and then the
dynamic Library as well now this is
currently root
um and it's also not marked as
executable so if we try and execute it
it's not going to let us so let's just
do a pseudo CH mod plus X into well
probably everything here to be honest if
we take a look now they're executable
um they're root you don't want to run
this as root definitely not that's just
honestly a disaster what you want to do
is make a new user only give them access
to like a certain directory and then run
this as that user because that will
prevent your program from destroying the
rest of your server and because
connection to the network it could be a
potential vulnerability I'm not going to
do that here because I don't care about
this server no offense to hostinger
because this is obviously just a demo
but you definitely don't do this I'm
just being lazy and I probably shouldn't
be so if we try running it now
um it'll tell us error while loading
shared libraries now this is something
like I mean look the library is right
here so you might be like why is this
happening the thing is on Windows dlls
in the same directory as your exe just
get picked up automatically that's just
how it works that's not quite the case
for Linux uh at least I mean in my
experience it hasn't been I don't know
maybe I'm missing something so what I
like to do is there's this like user lib
location that you just have with a bunch
of different libraries I think what I
did on that computer is I made a
directory called like local or something
and then I ended up basically taking
this which remember is an app slash that
so if I just do copy app slash that into
here
um you can see I now have that here uh
and then we can type in export LD
Library path equals this path that we've
just kind of created so I'll just paste
that in run sudo ldconfig and that's it
that should have hopefully work so if we
go back to app and uh I guess we'll just
put it in here and we try and run that
uh you can see it's got a different file
that it can't find because I've got to
grab that one but this is actually kind
of distributed in a package so we don't
really need to handle that manually if
we don't want to uh you can run sudo apt
is it list yeah let's cut that pseudo
apt list and then we can just grab
Proto buff or something so you can see
there's quite a lot that we can actually
use here let's try this guy this is my
strategy for just getting this to work
uh okay so after doing some like
Googling uh protobuf compiler seems to
be the thing we want so sudo app to
install that 50 meg okay not bad that
includes a bunch of dependencies the
protobuf has as well of course
um and now maybe if we run our app
server headless
we did it
look at that it's running hello
uh okay so now I suppose we should try
connecting to this uh let me just keep
this here this is uh very exciting let
me grab this so this is our this is the
Headless one I want the GUI one so that
has the client okay so there's app
client sure let's just hit F5 I'm very
excited this is our server over here
okay here's our Walnut chat client let
me pick a name yarn orange of course uh
and if we go back to hosting art real
quick just to grab that IP address we
can just put that in now we know it's
going to be Port 8192 so let's type that
in 8192 connect connecting
we're in hello
look at that
hi
and we get that over here
um okay let's start another instance of
this so if you right click go debug
start a new instance a lot of people
don't know that it's handy you can see
it loads our settings but now let's
connect as Cherno who will be green for
some reason
connect
and we're in you can see we download our
yarn Hello message let me just set this
up a bit better ah it's all very
exciting when you finally see it working
for the first time hey man
then you spend hours talking to yourself
now that's the next step really what's
up so this is a three-way a three-way
chart
between Cherno yarn and server
um okay so let's try kicking someone
let's kick Cherno
Cherno
okay so user channel has been kicked you
can see it's brought up the connection
uh dialogue you can just rejoin by the
way that's
no stay out I accidentally did kick with
without an argument
um because your channel just joining and
leaving good riddance
I hate that guy hours of fun honestly
hours of entertainment uh and then if we
do quit I think the server will did I
not implement the Quick Command well if
we control C does this just I guess this
will just like disconnect after a bit of
time and if I try hey it won't do
anything
yep there it is so that's gone now and
if I try connecting it's won't be able
to of course because the server is down
there it is just stops after a while but
if I restart the server I connect
we should be able to get in
and there you go
Haze everywhere so thank you guys for
watching this video I hope you enjoyed
it all of this source code is going to
be on GitHub just for free for you guys
to take a look at and learn from
um I guess I should probably add some
disclaimers and that is the fact that
there's no security really to this uh so
you know use at your own risk people can
obviously manipulate these messages they
can write custom clients I've written
the server in a way that hopefully won't
result in everything being destroyed uh
if I'm wrong in saying that please let
me know and from this kind of Mega video
I have a few spin-offs that I kind of
want to make uh maybe like a code review
of all of this because I haven't really
gone through the code in detail and also
getting Walnut like with the UI so the
non-handless Walnut the head Walnut to
run on Linux because at the moment that
doesn't so this client only works on
Windows the server of course in headless
mode does run on Linux that's what we're
doing here but not the GUI client so
that might be an interesting video just
kind of bringing Walnut onto Linux onto
Ubuntu because I haven't done but let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
hopefully this was a good video and was
helpful uh to you guys who want to play
around with networking again game
networking sockets just a really really
good library to use I really like it
would work valve uh and we've stolen a
bunch of code from Hazel so maybe Hazel
will steal some code from Walnut and
actually end up integrating something
like this client server API or whatever
into Hazel so that we can make
multiplayer games in the future speaking
of which also might be nice to use this
to actually make a multiplayer game so
maybe that lies in the future as well
anyway thank you guys for watching don't
forget to check out hostinger.com Cherno
to get your server and I will see you
guys next time goodbye